[Music]
this week on
forward so the challenge really is can
either party break away from their quote
unquote
incumbent in order to present a better
alternative to the country it's C of
kind of prisoners dilemma right I mean
it's not like you know everyone's going
to naturally do the thing that's sort of
best for the system as a whole I think
the tastes and desires of the political
class on both sides is really sits on
the opposite side of uh of workingclass
Voters and you know I really feel like
job as a pollster is really to bring
that perspective especially if it's not
demographically who I
[Music]
am it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast political vet holster co-founder
of echelon insights and author of the
very informative new book party of the
people inside the multi-racial populist
Co Coalition remaking the GOP Patrick
graini welcome Patrick great to be here
Andrew so Patrick you are a data wonk a
nerd it's good fun um I I got to say I
haven't read a book this chalk full of
data in quite some time how does one
become a pollster well it's an
interesting question because I initially
start out as a pollster I started out
doing uh the digital side of campaigning
and uh working with a lot of data and
really learning my way as a
pollster um uh based on a lot of that
initial experience trying to bring in
more of that initial experience so
polling is not all that I do a lot of it
is data work a lot of it is sort of
figuring out what we can learn from
digital insights but um you know I I
mean I I really feel like you're seeing
it right now with so many young people
um uh you have it on Election Twitter
you've got these places where people are
conversing about individual races or
conversing about Trends in particular
State we States we have so much
availability of data now that really the
field is wide open for anyone to join in
fact to high school students this could
be like he it's time to become like like
Patrick it's good fun um so we're going
to talk about your book and then we're
going to talk about 2024 because I'm
sure you're on TV all the time being
asked about 2024 but first this book
that I thought was really really well
done I think this is your first book
correct yes it's a lot it's a lot of
work you clearly did a lot of work what
spurred you to write this book and uh
what is the the big idea yeah the big
idea is that you know our parties have
fundamentally changed so when I first
got involved in politics about 20 years
ago um it was taken as an article of
faith that um there was a class divide
in American politics and the Democrats
stood on the S of the worker in that
class divide they stood on the side of
uh you know the common man they went by
the sort of nickname party of the people
and at their best you know the Democrats
represented this broad middle class
majority and were able to successfully
Define Republicans as uh Defenders Of
The Rich Defenders of the wealthy we saw
that uh you know most recently I feel
like in
2012 uh where Barack Obama very
effectively did that to Mitt Romney uh
you know portraying as him as a Titan of
private equity and out of touch with
average Working Families and I feel like
really that definition in the Trump area
has gone out the window uh and it's gone
out the window because of the decisions
of uh people on both sides of the aisle
both Donald Trump redefining the
Republican Party more in populist terms
redefining it less in terms of uh you
know we are going to have strict
economic conservatism with spending cuts
and tax cuts um and and uh the Democrats
responding in kind saying uh you know
Trump represents a threat to democracy a
cultural threat more than he does a
threat to let's say Working Families
which was sort of the core of the bread
and butter economic messaging of the
democratic party as a result we've seen
a dramatic realignment of Voters right
in this era where it's not only you have
your white working class voters in the
Upper Midwest uh moving towards the
Republicans and your white college
educated voters in the suburbs moving
towards the Democrats but you're
increasingly seeing non-white voters in
play for Republicans um because of this
change in emphasis on on the side of
both parties all right so here's the big
idea in 2004 uh this idea emerged from a
book The emerging Democratic majority
that said the country is getting more
diverse diverse people vote Democratic
uh it's getting less white rural uh
and old uh young people also like
Democrats more so the Democrats will
experience a winded their backs by
virtue of demographics that will lead to
a sustained majority and this was borne
out in part by Obama's resounding
victory in ' 08 uh his victory in 2012
didn't completely debunk it but in many
ways your book is the big fact-based
Counterpoint saying whoa whoa whoa it
turns out that that is not correct
because of the fact that now the single
biggest deal in American politics is not
whether you're white or non-white it's
whether you have a college degree or not
is that a fair summary yeah I think so I
I I think that like there in the wake of
the Obama victories there was definitely
a thought process on the left that said
look at all the groups that Obama won
winning young voters by 2 to1 winning uh
you know these expanded majorities among
African-Americans doing much better
among Latinos that all these groups are
just growing are going to become more
influential in the years to come and so
uh you know we don't really need to
change our message and we don't need to
moderate our message in order to win um
that we can just wait for the
demographic tides to eventually make it
so that uh you know we are going to see
the end of you know white Christian
conservative America I think was one of
the titles of books you know kind of the
titles of books that came out in this
era but that was a dramatic misreading
of both what Obama actually did and uh
both demographically and uh you know
message wise so um you know what you
actually saw uh you know during the
Obama era was he him appealing very
effectively uh to these um you know
Working Class People specifically white
Working Class People in
deindustrializing parts of the country
so he did extremely well in the Upper
Midwest and Midwestern states in States
like Michigan and that we're
experiencing um you know we're
experiencing an economic collapse
because the Auto industry uh was
collapsing and he very effectively
promoted the auto bailout in 2012 and
made that a major dividing line in that
election so I think people like to focus
on look at all the things he did with
young progressives right and and
mobilizing young Gros and he did that
but it was within a coalition of Voters
who were more conservative
temperamentally which was kind of that
white working class Midwestern Auto
worker factory worker uh that voted for
Obama and then shift over to voting for
Trump so what happens when uh what
happens in that you know scenario is
that the Democrats start blaming really
start um start attacking um those voters
who you know calling them racists
calling them people who uh you know are
racially resentful but they in fact they
voted for Obama so how how can that be
true it was you know Trump uniquely
spoke to them in the in in the same way
that Obama uniquely spoke to them and I
think um you know it's funny because you
mentioned the emerging Democratic
majority and that was really kind of how
it was interpreted right as this surge
of non-white and Progressive uh voices
in the electorate but um the authors of
that book have a new book out actually
that uh and they have already said like
no this was wasn't going to come true
because specifically our book really
also said you need to worry about the
white working class you need to maintain
hold serve with the white working class
Democrats and they just haven't done so
and in fact the rhetoric towards those
workingclass voters in the midwest um
has been anything but welcoming since
2016 oh yeah I I campaigned a lot in the
Midwest and I ran into a lot of white
working-class voters who do not think
the Democratic party was into
them those part of it uh and uh there's
a guy named David Shore who you site uh
and seem seemingly agree with that um
one of the things that's happened is
Democratic party messaging has gotten
taken over by uh college graduate
concerns uh and that the messaging
thoughts hits harder among college
graduates not shockingly one one thing I
enjoyed about your book is it pointed
out a set of facts that people often do
not realize which is that only about 35%
of Voters have a college degree in full
um 65% don't the average voter is Maybe
50 52 years old and so when you start
visualizing that voter you have a much
better read uh on on things so do you
think that the Republican
party and this is one thing I'm I'm
interested in is that so the Democratic
political class is obviously dominated
by college graduates I mean I've met a
lot of those people I can't remember
virtually anyone who who didn't have a
college degree um now among Republicans
I'd imagine it's the same but are are do
they just do a better job of somehow uh
avoiding certain types of appeals that
only work on College grads it's it's yes
and no right I think this is really
interesting in the era of trump what has
happened to a lot many people in the
Republican political class who again
share who are all college graduates
right I mean it's practically a requ a
de facto requirement for working in
politics and you know really um that's
media too yeah we get right I mean it's
not necessarily that we require people
are required to have a college degree
but culturally speaking like that's who
ends up working on campaigns that's who
ends up working in media and uh you know
that didn't used to be a problem prior
to 2012 where there wasn't this huge
education divide in the country that you
know you you had college graduates who
were roughly speaking in line with the
views of non- colle graduates right but
um in post 2016 that is no longer the
case and so I I think it's interesting
in the sense of you have the same
problem on the right in the sense of you
had so many people who during
2016 this happened to some extent to me
that were really disillusioned by Donald
Trump were really disillusioned by SC he
did not like what was happening and I
think it was stylistically you had so
many Republicans who have more moderate
positions on social issues but who are
more economically conservative and as I
show in the book that's not really when
you survey voters that is not really
where most voters are most most voters
if they're if they're cross pressured on
social and economic issues are more
economically liberal and socially
conservative um so in many ways the I
think the tastes and desires of the
political class on both sides is really
sits on the opposite side of uh of
workingclass Voters and you know I
really feel like my job as a pollster is
really to bring that perspective in even
though it's not like even if it's not
demographically who I am especially if
it's not demographically who I am I need
to bring those perspectives in um to
show people like this is how most people
are thinking this is the world viiew of
most people as opposed to you know kind
of projecting my own worldview onto a
lot of people who don't hold those ISS
hold those same
priorities how are you going to get
healthier this year one way to do so is
have healthy chef-crafted meals
delivered to your door stressfree what
the heck am I talking about Factor
Factor's 2-minute meals are your secret
step into a healthier happier you I've
been eating factor for this last number
of weeks and wow it's been a game
changer we're talking about delicious
chicken taco bowl spicy pablano beef and
every time I'm like ooh this is going to
be tasty and it is makes you feel good
it's cost efficient it's flexible no
prep no mess you can't screw it up just
poke a couple holes in it heat it up and
it it's fresh never Frozen I got to say
if you try Factor you are going to be
pumped it's going to make you healthier
happier more productive in the New Year
head to factor meals.com
y50 and use code y50 to get 50% off
that's code
y50 factor meals.com
y50 to get 50% off
Factor
in my view your book uh if I would to
simplify it um here's the message is
that there are a lot of non- colge
educated non-white voters that Democrats
in the political class assume of course
they got to vote for us because we're
the party of the diverse and uh what are
they going to do vote the Republicans
the Republicans are racist um but it
turns out in real life uh a lot of
nonwhite non college graduates uh
actually are very into the Republican
party uh where Trump is competing at
parody among Latino populations in
various parts of the country um there's
been a drift towards the Republican
Party among uh asian-americans you can
even see a little bit of it in the black
community albeit from a very very low
base uh and that struck me as the the
underpinning of this is that look if you
just assumed every Latino Asian uh black
voter is going to vote Dem atic and
those populations are going to rise then
all set
Democrats and and what you're saying is
whoa whoa whoa if you look at the data
it turns out that Democrats have
increasingly become the party of the
college educated and that if you're a
non-college educated Latino Asian or
black voter you're actually going to be
drifting towards the GOP hence the GOP
becoming this multi-racial Coalition
party uh is that uh did I get that right
yeah I mean I think that um you know
this book and I think I wouldn't say
this book specifically I think reality
has challenged a lot of those
assumptions that um people made about
the electorate so you know specifically
one of the major failings of this
demography as Destiny theory was that
Latinos would behave the same way as
black voters have historically as
members of a cohesive identity group
that would move Democratic on the issue
of immigration
because they favored more legal
immigration or favored more uh you know
a more open immigration policy that
included a pathway to citizenship for
illegal immigrants and that was really
kind of the major thinking around 2012
you know that has been proven wrong I
think partly because you sort of
misunderstood it misunderstands the
motivation of most Latino voters most
Latino voters don't see themselves as
part of this unified block of people
they certainly don't see themselves as
Latin X but yeah they see they don't
always necessarily see themselves as as
part of this pan Latino Community right
um when you actually talk to them you
people say I'm Mexican I'm Venezuelan
but more more often than that uh they
just kind of see themselves as regular
Americans I mean I think in a lot of
places they're very third you know
you've got people are many of them are
are deeply religious and part of a like
a church Community right and so I don't
think you can mobilize them right on
this sort of identity politics
um but I think that there's also a risk
right where Democrats feel right now
they have a little bit of an initiative
on this abortion issue which I I think
you know to some extent look you can't
argue with the election results in some
of these states that have had referenda
on the issue but I I think they're not
necessarily thinking about how they're
branding and defining their party right
um you know that I think from a
coalitional standpoint you've got a lot
of people who are in with in the
Democratic party who have more
conservative views on social issues than
have more conservative views on let's
say economic issues and so long term
when the political you know sugar high
of that issue kind of recedes what are
you left with you're left with a party
that is defined more and more by its
left of center views on cultural issues
than it you know has it had been defined
whereas it had been defined previously
by really standing up for the working
class who are the majority vast majority
of the country um based on lines of
college educations and on economics too
I would love love love for the
Democratic party uh or any party to
start hitting policies and messages that
would appeal to the non-white non-
college educated workingclass of this
country because if you improve their
lives you're probably doing something
great you're probably doing something
that brings down the cost of housing
bring down brings down the cost of
healthare brings down the cost of
Education uh makes it more affordable to
be you know the um mother or father of a
child make you feel better about the
future so that would make me very very
excited I certainly think that uh I I
was on CNN a while ago and I said look
um you know what people don't like is a
political party as the culture of police
it's like hey you say or do the wrong
thing you use the wrong word you're not
keeping track of the
terminology then you're you're somehow
in the outs I mean that that that is a
very very uh esoteric message that does
not speak to the non-white working class
like um so so that that's something I
would love to see parties take uh wisdom
um from you and your data uh in in those
regards I mean it it seems like you
think the Democratic party it's it's not
going to pick up on this and clearly
there have been a number of people David
Shaw among them who have been like hey
guys maybe should do something that
people actually
want you look at the data and then you
know and then you pointed out David
Shore actually lost a job um in in part
because you know he he said something
that went against the Orthodoxy um in a
particular way uh so you're staring at
numbers more than any any of the rest of
us even more than me even though I do it
a fair amount so when when this airs
Republicans will just be about to start
voting in the Republican primary um so
my read on it is that it's going to be
Trump Trump trump uh that Nikki Haley is
his strongest opponent um but because of
the fragmented field uh it's likely that
Trump wins Iowa uh it will come down to
New Hampshire is and then Nikki has to
win South Carolina to have any chance to
be viable uh thereafter but that it's uh
unlikely that we're probably looking at
a trump nomination uh does the data tell
you that the same thing yeah I mean what
what the data is showing right now uh
and it's um uh you're starting to see
some movement upward for niiki hilly in
New Hampshire particularly because that
is a very independent-minded electorate
as you well know uh and that you have a
lot of crossover voters uh in the New
Hampshire primary that could upend uh
you know certainly has upended the
previous Front Runners uh and uh has
frustrated the path to the nomination
that when when people are are supposed
to Wal the nomination usually hit a
stumbling block in New Hampshire but I
think in general we're starting to see
across the board on both the Republican
and the Democratic side is the early
States simply aren't mattering as much
because I think voters overall are
really T more tuned in and engaged at a
baseline level than they have been in
maybe decades past and so you know
National polls actually I mean they're
not predictive I think you you want to
take the first reading of the national
poll after Iowa after New Hampshire to
really confirm what direction this is
going um but I also think that you know
let's not forget Trump was the president
Trump is a strong front runner for the
nomination he hasn't really made any
major stumbles if you're not counting
his coni you know if you're not counting
his criminal cases he hasn't really made
any major stumbles in the nomination uh
fight and so uh you know he'll be tough
to dislodge because he's not like a
conventional kind of normal party front
runner he you know actually has come
back from being president before so uh
um so I do think it's a it's a tough
road um for Nikki hilly or for Ronda
santis or someone else but I do think we
could see a surprise especially in New
Hampshire hey YouTube thanks for
watching please do hit like And
subscribe and hit that Bell if you want
to be notified every time a new episode
drops probably on Mondays but hit that
Bell and thank
you
oh wow New Hampshire January 23rd uh
which we're going to return to in just a
minute um because I I'm very very keyed
into what New Hampshire does in January
23rd so the numbers also have Joe
Biden's support really kind of
collapsing over the last two or three
months um it's been jarring to see the
composite right now has him at 38% he's
been as low as 37% Pew had him at 33%
which is crazy crazy uh I mean that's
low um and it it's much lower than let's
say Obama was uh in 2012 at this stage
which was 48% Obama obviously went on to
beat Roundy anyone who was close to
where Joe is went on to lose which
included Jimmy Carter um Joe's numbers
are worse than Carter's were I mean I
think about that one because like you
think about Jimmy Carter presiding over
uh a really difficult uh period And so
two three months ago if you'd asked me
Hey Joe Biden versus Donald Trump's toss
up it's going to be close you can see it
either way now Trump is up by according
to Bloomberg 10 in Michigan five in
Georgia virtually tied in Minnesota
which is a state that Biden won by seven
points in 2020 you look at some of those
numbers in individual states and just
blanket 37 38% approval rating it feels
like Trump wins in the general uh if the
election was held today uh do you agree
with that assessment I think he's got to
be considered at least a slight favorite
um for the uh and you have to should
take the polls at face value but it's a
year out right so there's a large error
band on on on that prediction but um but
you just just taking the polls at at
face value which I do that I do think
that Biden is in
trouble so so uh gently put um well part
two because you know I mean like one two
three polls like okay okay but now I
I've seen 13 PS I me you know like like
the picture is pretty uh comprehensive
right I mean so before right the idea
was well Trump is never going to lead in
a poll right I mean 2016 2020 you never
saw Trump actually leading in the polls
right you saw was well Trump is keeping
a close and maybe he's got this weird
coalitional thing in the Electoral
College that's going to put him over the
top right and now there's no there's no
you know he's still got the electoral
college right Advantage right because I
think when you have a workingclass
coalition that's going to over index for
states that lean a little bit more red
and especially in this new alignment
you've got States like Michigan um that
are going to start voting to the right
of the country as a whole even though
the state Republican party there is a
complete absolute mess so it's no thanks
to the state Republican party in
Michigan um but what you're starting to
see is demographically it's a state that
um you know really does favor Trump
Trump but you know Biden is also maybe
having some trouble with the Arab
American vote in Detroit that could
explain part of this but um but um but
what you're starting to see is sort of
you know the Democrats kind of neglect
of you know voters in this Upper Midwest
uh Midwestern band of States um has
really made them to the point where
again it's not only do you have Trump
has maybe an advantage in some of those
states that are specifically very
critical to the electoral college but he
also have has now a popular vote
advantage and by the way he has a
popular vote Advantage because the polls
at least right now are showing him
gaining you know a really strong uh
strong gains among both
African-Americans and Latino voters uh
over and above uh what he did in 20120
which is actually quite limited on the
African-American front more impressive
on the Latino front but the polls right
now are showing him improving and I
think when you look at the issue set
it's no surprise why right uh you know
the issues of cost of living um you know
economy now and you know that's going to
hit the working class hardest yeah uh
young people too in in these polls uh
you know there's one poll that had Trump
Had parody among young people which
again is pretty disastrous uh for Joe
Biden you mentioned Arab Americans in
Michigan I think that they're three or
four per of the population which even if
they just don't show up to vote for
Biden uh then that that's the margin of
Victory right there now we're talking
about these polls and you said hey look
Trump you wouldn't expect him to be
ahead but he has some advantages in the
Electoral College and the composition of
his vote share um uh in Reverse Biden
kind of needs a several point lead to be
at parody right because of the way that
these that that the map shakes out like
uh like Biden plus two is essentially a
tie so Biden minus two 2 or three has
essentially has him down Five Points um
do do I have that essentially cor
correct that's right I mean there's
there's some there's some pundits that
say that's not really true anymore if
you you know again if Trump is making
all these gains with let's say Latinos
right he's going to shift California
right he's going to shift New York right
he's going to shift some of these states
right that are blue States and so it
doesn't it's not going to matter as much
we will see if that's the case he kind
of did that in 2020 and it got worse but
it's kind of luck of the draw right I
you kind of need to get lucky in some of
these states right uh you know uh so
maybe you know the upside for Democrats
it's kind of like 2022 right where they
don't actually win the popular vote for
the house at least um but they really
make a strong case in these very tight
Biden voting like Biden plus two
districts right can't elect the
Republicans because they're going to
overturn the results of the election
they're kind of crazy and they actually
successfully make the case specifically
in those districts and in those seats I
think it's going to be harder to do I
think the Dynamics this year have
shifted
um you know and it's more of an economic
argument and you are you know
potentially making it against somebody
again remember you're just really it's
gonna be the top of the ticket this time
like Biden wasn't on the top of the
ticket in 22 and by the way he didn't
even campaign in a lot of these places
because his numbers were underwater so
everyone was like don't worry about it
we got it exactly right but but I also
just think like a lot of things you hear
in focus groups so right I just remember
I maybe voted for Biden last time and I
think but the reason people say they
voted for Biden sometimes is because I
didn't like the chaos under Trump I
didn't like what he was doing on racial
issues I didn't like you know kind of
the sense like things were kind of off
the rails um but the economy was good
right and now the economy for a lot of
people isn't as good at least perception
wise and we can talk about what the
reality is but the perception is the
perception and perception often becomes
reality and so um you know the right now
what they're doing is just comparing the
economic performance and the perceived
economic performance of both of these
people TR Trump is up 25 points among
Independents on that issue the
economy this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn when you go to the bathroom
you always close the door behind you
because you don't want random people
seeing what you're doing but when you go
online people sometimes can see what
you're doing I'm talking about those big
tech companies and other folks who might
not have your best interest at at heart
that's why I use expressvpn and you
should too this way your data stays
yours it can't be sold and resold when I
use expressvpn you just click one button
transports you to another server and
also give you access to fun content that
might be available in another country
it's like you're a global traveler
without ever leaving your home get an
extra 3 months of expressvpn free by
going to expressvpn.com yangang that's
expressvpn.com yangang for three extra
months free expressvpn.com
[Music]
so Patrick here's my perspective uh
let's say I don't want Donald Trump to
be president which I don't I mean
shocker um uh and I think that Biden uh
in 2020 might have been the strongest
nominee the Democrats could field and in
2024 he's the weakest uh you know 37%
approval people are fed up he's going to
he's going to be turning 82 essentially
uh and it's very hard to reinvent
Grandpa what uh you know I was saying um
they spent $25 million to boost his
numbers in the swing States and it had
zero effect the biomics thing is a total
dud uh that they should never have named
the economy after
him and that if you're the Democrats and
you want to defeat Donald Trump the move
is to switch nominees you should have a
primary uh Dean Phillips is already in
the field I think Dean would be a much
stronger opponent against Trump than Joe
because Dean's 54 no one's heard of him
so people don't hate him yet and that
this is the
greatest opportunity because the
majority of democratic voters are
uncomfortable with Joe too uh you know I
mean I voted for Joe I campaigned for
Joe I'm uncomfortable you know like I
and I'm really uncomfortable with the
fact that the Democratic part is not
having a process I mean that is demented
where you have in this case a sitting
member of Congress raising his hand
saying hey guys like I'm running too and
they're and you know places like Florida
like no no no um I mean that that is
nuts especially given the head-to-head
picture between Biden and Trump um so
what are your thoughts on generic
Democrat versus Trump uh as opposed to
Joe Biden versus Trump I think generic
anyone wins in this cycle right I mean
if you had generic Republican against
Biden it wouldn't I mean it's not maybe
maybe it's not close now it's kind of
close it would not be close and you saw
H Nicki Haley was up 17 against Joe
Biden in the Wall Street Journal po what
I think that's reflective of is you know
with all due respect to Nikki Haley and
I think she is a formidable candidate
but I think that's more reflective of we
just want someone else uh you know
anyone else someone else someone else
someone else put up the chat someone
else someone
else
um I I think Nikki haly would trounce
Joe Biden the general of Nikki Hy where
the the nominee you know I mean what
we're saying goes on both sides the
polls I saw had generic Republican
beating Joe Biden by 10 you know all the
way up to 17 uh on the flip side generic
Democrat beats Trump by let's call it
eight uh and so the challenge really is
can either party break away from their
quote unquote
incumbent in order to present the better
alternative to the country it's C of
kind of prisoners dilemma right I mean
it's not like you know everyone's going
to naturally do the thing that's sort of
best for the system as a whole that each
party has kind of these internal
Dynamics and internal imperatives that
you know the Democrats believe that uh
you know this would be too uh fragmented
a process that it would be too damaging
internally to the party and I think the
main reason though beyond beyond the
sort of it would be messy right is the
fear they might end up with kamalo right
I mean that's that's sort of really the
main barrier oh my gosh pck you think
that's the he's a human shield right
here in the situation right that you
know you don't want to you know you
don't want to get rid of him because you
could end up with her he has you know if
if anyone might be even weaker than Joe
Biden it could be her well you know if
you have a competitive primary kamalo
runs then you know see how it shakes out
I mean I think everyone would be okay
with that I I personally don't think
calo would emerge from that process um
and uh but hey you know if you have a
real competitive Democratic primary um
then everyone can have at it uh I I'm uh
deeply concerned about uh the Democrats
essentially shrugging our our way into a
loss to Trump shrugging their way into a
loss to Trump um and so this is why I'm
so laser focused on New Hampshire voting
on January 23rd uh because at least one
poll I saw had Dean Phillips at 15% and
Joe Biden at 27% with the mass undecided
and Joe Biden um because of his
punishment of New Hampshire his name
does not appear in the ballot so people
have to write him in which I'm going to
suggest will probably uh you know reduce
his number somewhat so if if Dean
Phillips uh can grow grow grow and
defeat the sitting president in the
first state I feel like everyone's going
to snap to attention and say wait what
just happened because right now the
dominant message people are getting is
like oh it's Joe it's Joe and a lot of
folks are are very uncomfortable with
that and being like really that's a
plan that if if New Hampshire says it's
not Joe then everyone will be like it's
not Joe and and then uh a real process
might break out so to me January 23rd is
the date what happens in New Hampshire
um are you similarly focused on New
Hampshire on both sides I mean if it's
you know the only I am I am focused on
New Hampshire I'm focused on you know
the possibility in the Republican side
could there be an upset um there's a
recent poll Nikki Haley sort of within
15 points of trump in New Hampshire
based on the strength of independent
voters and you still have Chris Christie
taking up 10 10% so do his voters going
migrate to her um but yeah on the
Democratic side it's just it's really
tough to see
because um you know you might think Dean
Phillips is Dean Phillips is in the
race um are they actually going to
nominate Dean Phillips
probably not um I I think you know he he
was trying to position himself as kind
of a stalking horse for maybe a more
prominent figure agression Whitmer
somebody to jump in at the end so it's
it's really hard to see what the game
plan is beyond that right um because if
if Biden shows really dramatic weakness
in some of his early primaries um what
is Plan B are you really gonna ra is it
the party really going to Rally around
Dean Phillips or you know is there a way
mechanically to uh shift it to maybe in
the late you know maybe somebody jumps
in and but then you know I'm I'm I'm
sort of blissfully you're a primary
filing deadlines here so but um that
would be the scenario and it's kind of a
1968 or does it convince Biden okay you
know it really doesn't make sense to run
um but then it's a really Insider driven
process at that point which I don't
think um you know people especially
within the Democratic party would be
very happy
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a new year time to make yourself
better rested more energized and a great
way to do that is with a helix sleep
mattress I took their quiz and I said
you know what I roll around a lot I
sleep in my back I need a lot of support
and I got matched with a dawn Lux
mattress that has become a game changer
not just for me but for my kids it's
their favorite mattress even though it
wasn't designed for them Helix will now
actually tailor mattresses specifically
for Big and Tall customers and for kids
they have a 100 night trial you can try
the mattress for 3 months send it back
and attend a 15year warranty it's the
top rated Mattress By wired and many
other Publications don't take my word
for it try it out for yourself Helix is
offering 20% off off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
go to helixsleep.com
yangang and use code Helix partner 20
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts
[Music]
now well I I think this is the the plan
Patrick that Joe Biden wakes up on
January 24th he's like wait I lost New
Hampshire I'm 81 years old I'm at 37% in
the polls like what what's happening and
then someone goes up to him and says Joe
according to our numbers you're you're
gonna be neck and neck with Dean in M
Michigan too this thing's gonna drag out
uh and then Joe Biden decides to go
George Washington and say as a Statesman
uh I'm going to be passing the Baton to
the Next Generation he'd then be able to
have a very heavy hand in the process to
your point and if it winds up Dean
Phillips who I think would defeat Trump
great if it winds up with another
candidate who I think could defeat Trump
great um but that to me is the the great
opportunity because if we just let this
play out uh I don't think Joe's numers
all of a sudden shoot up uh you know I I
think it's difficult
to rejuvenate energy around a candidate
who is going is going to be campaigning
at 81 and anytime you're with you see
him you think wow he is not the same as
he was even four years ago yeah I mean I
think I take your point I mean I think
that that is uh that's right um that uh
you know this could create a panic
situation if you know in fact Dean
Phillips is able to Edge out Biden now
of course they'll say well he wasn't on
the ballot they have an excuse right so
they're going to try and test it but I
mean I really feel like uh you know
politics these days is really uh parties
are making decisions for really
shortterm reasons right uh you know
Republicans can't get rid of of trump
because if you get rid of trump you are
just admitting the Deep state was right
or if you get rid of Biden you're going
to have this chaotic process and so my
fear is like kind of he hangs on right
uh you know he you know he tries to hang
on and I think that's sort of been the
pattern because you know sometimes you
can hang on in in difficult
circumstances and come back and win I
also think that you know the the faith
in the polling industry right now right
is so poor that I feel like the polls
are probably going to be a lot of people
feel like the polls are going to be off
by more than they're going to move over
the next year right I mean we could see
essentially the same thing over the next
year the polls saying what they say and
then oops it's it either Trump wins in a
huge Landslide or Biden somehow eeks it
out I mean I think there's all this this
hopium right the people are taking that
oh well the polls you can't believe the
polls you can't trust the polls you've
got these ular partisan Echo Chambers
where people are repeating them this
stuff to themselves every day and I'm
like no as a pollster I say no you can't
necessarily take everything we say is
Gospel right but uh we need to have some
grounding in reality right you need to
have some common sense here I'm with you
man and you know one poll two polls I
think okay maybe maybe not but when it
starts getting past like the 20 polls
then I was like okay this might actually
reflect reality and certainly Someone
Like You traffics in reality and data
it's one reason why I enjoyed your book
so much is that I was chalk full of real
life facts and math and numbers from
around the country over the last period
of years and IT projects forward what uh
the election could look like in let's
say
2036 which I I very much enjoyed uh it's
only through data like yours that you
get a real sense of what the future can
hold so congratulations on this book
party of the people inside the the
multi-racial populist Coalition remaking
the GOP how can people keep up with you
and your work Patrick so yeah I I'm on
I'm at my name Patrick raffini on most
platforms including X Twitter uh you
know threads all those places and I also
have a substack at www. Patrick
grain.com um where uh I send out my
longer form pieces well congratulations
on this very very fact-based book uh I
learned a lot from it and uh you know
maybe we'll have you back to talk about
how the heck this uh this primary season
plays out thanks so
[Music]
much